four girls
already traumatized by their life in
gaza
now trying to understand why their
friend the fifth in their group
dima is gone
they spoke to us with the agreement and
supervision of a specialist from the
norwegian refugee council
their memories of their friend are now
in videos
from the center where they are now being
helped we drove to the gebalia
neighborhood of gaza
where their friend lived and where she
died
her uncle showed us the spot where she
was walking at 8 pm
last tuesday she'd been to a neighbor's
house to collect a bread maker
the electricity was back briefly and her
mother wanted to do some baking
both sides in this conflict accuse the
other of killing
civilians but what dimas family need is
the truth
it will go some way to helping them
recover
because at the moment they're broken
this is deemer's motherless
oh
[Music]
foreign
the child trauma specialists are helping
them to process it all
she tried to to tell them
that to imagine
a place this safe place
it exists you can go there whenever you
want
trauma and grief there are two things
which come early here
mark stone sky news in gaza